Hiç düşündünüz mü? Sosyal medyada
yazdığımız her bir kelime konuştuğumuz
dili aslında nasıl değiştiriyor? Bugün
çok ilginç bir konuya dalıyoruz.
Türkiye'den bir ders kitabını ele
alacağız ve bu sorunun ne kadar ciddiye
alındığına hatta gençlere bu konuda
nasıl bir misyon yüklendiğine birlikte
bakacağız. Hazırsanız hadi başlayalım.
Peki her şey nerede başlıyor? Aslında
her şey dili sevmekle başlıyor. Çünkü
göreceksiniz bu mesele Türkiye'de kuru
bir dil bilgisi kuralından çok daha
fazlası adeta bir Evet. Bir kalp
meselesi.
Bakın ünlü yazar Sait Faik abası yanık
ne demiş? Bir insanı sevmekle başlar her
şey. Çok güçlü bir söz değil mi? Her
şeyin özünde sevgi var. Peki ya bu
sevgiye, bu temel duyguya ana dilimizi
de eklesek nasıl olur? İşte ders kitabı
tam da bunu yapıyor. Sait Faik'in bu
güzel fikrini alıyor ve bir adım öteye
taşıyor. Diyor ki, "Ana dilini sevmek de
en az vatanını, insanını sevmek kadar
önemli. Hatta kutsal dil. Dil adeta
kimliğimizin attığı yer, kalbimiz. Ve
burada bahsettiğimiz dil öyle
küçümsenecek bir dil de değil.
Türkçe dünya sahnesinde gerçekten dev
bir oyuncu. Milyonlarca insanı bir araya
getiren, dünyanın en çok konuşulan, en
güçlü beş dilinden biri olarak
gösteriliyor. Ama bu kadar köklü, bu
kadar güçlü bir miras şimdi hepimizin
avucunun içinde tuttuğu, cebinde
taşıdığı bambaşka bir güçle karşı
karşıya. Tahmin ettiniz sosyal medya.
Yani şöyle düşünün, sosyal medya artık
sadece fikirlerimizi paylaştığımız bir
platform değil. Hayır, çok daha fazlası.
Konuşma şeklimizi, kullandığımız
kelimeleri, cümle kurma biçimimizi hatta
hangi emojiyi seçeceğimizi bile o
belirliyor. Resmen dilimize yön veriyor.
Hatta ders kitabındaki benzetme o kadar
çarpıcı ki durumu Matrix filmine
benzetiyorlar. Hatırlarsınız değil mi?
Yani diyor ki farkında bile olmadan
medyanın bizim için ördüğü bu sanal dil
ağının içine düşebiliriz. kendi
dilimizin kontrolünü tamamen
kaybedebiliriz. Gerçekten ürkütücü bir
düşünce. Ve işte geldik en kritik
noktaya. O da ne biliyor musunuz?
Dilimize özen gösterme, onu koruma
sorumluluğunu biz kendi ellerimizle
farkında bile olmadan sosyal medyaya
yani o kullandığımız bir avuç uygulamaya
devrediyoruz. Artık bunun doğrusu neydi
diye düşünmüyoruz. Onun yerine ne
diyoruz? Ya boş ver herkes böyle yazıyor
zaten. İşte bu sorumluluk devri. Peki
bunun sonuçları ne oluyor? Birincisi,
dilimizin o kendine has renkleri o
zenginliği yavaş yavaş kayboluyor. Her
şey tek tip, monoton bir hale geliyor ve
belki de en tehlikelisi. Yanlış
kullanımlar o kadar çok yayılıyor, o
kadar çok tekrar ediliyor ki bir süre
sonra insanlar onu doğru zannetmeye
başlıyor. Peki tamam. Sorun bu. Türk
eğitim sistemi buna karşı ne yapıyor?
Sadece bir ders anlatıp geçiyor mu?
Hayır. Cevabı çok daha etkili. bir
görev, bir misyon veriyor. Karşınızda
Edebiyat atölyesi. Bu projeyle
öğrenciler sıradan öğrenciler olmaktan
çıkıyor. Adeta birer dil dedektifine
hatta dil koruyucusuna dönüşüyorlar.
Görevleri basit ama çok önemli.
Dillerini korumak ve o kaybolmaya yüz
tutan zenginliği yeniden günyüzüne
çıkarmak. Ve sakın bunu sıradan bir
dönem ödevi sanmayın. Hayır, hayır. Bu
beş adımdan oluşan neredeyse bir
stratejik operasyon gibi planlanmış
gerçek bir görev. Bakın adımlara.
Takımlar kur, istihbarat topla, analiz
et, sunum hazırla ve en önemlisi
farkındalık yarat. Amaç sadece bilgi
bulmak değil. Yani birilerini harekete
geçirmek. Evet. Şimdi o genç
dedektiflerin topladığı bilgilere yani
bulgularına yakından bakalım. Karşımıza
iki farklı dünya çıkıyor. Bir yanda
edebiyatın dili, diğer yanda, sosyal
medyanın dili. Gelin bu iki dünyayı bir
karşılaştıralım. Şu tablo aslında her
şeyi çok güzel özetliyor. Bakın, bir
tarafta zengin, incelikli, üzerinde
düşünülmüş edebi bir dil var. Diğer
tarafta ise ne var? Argo, kısaltmalar,
yabancı kelimeler, hız ve anında
iletişim için her şeyin
basitleştirildiği bir dil. Yani seçim
şu: Derinlik mi yoksa hız mı? İşte
öğrencilerin de dikkat çektiği temel
ikilem bu. Tabii ki bu verileri toplamak
işin sadece ilk adımı, savaşın yarısı
diyelim. Asıl önemli olan bu bilgilerle
bir şeyleri değiştirebilmek, insanların
düşünce yapısını etkilemek. Ve bu sunum
öyle herhangi bir sınıfta dört duvar
arasında yapılmıyor. Hayır. Öğrenciler
bu önemli bulgularını ulusal bir proje
olan Dilimizin Zenginlikleri
platformunda paylaşıyorlar. Yani tam da
ülkenin dil geleceğine yön verebilecek
insanların karşısında.
Peki dinleyici kitlesi kimler dersiniz?
İşte burası çok ilginç. Karşılarında
yazarlar, şairler, basın temsilcileri ve
evet sosyal medya fenomenlerinin
kendileri var. Yani dili profesyonel
olarak kullanan, kelimelerle kamuoyunu
şekillendiren herkes orada. Bu yüzden bu
gençlerin sunumu inanılmaz derecede
önemli. Peki tüm bu çabanın nihai hedefi
ne? Sosyal medyayı hayatımızdan çıkarmak
falan mı? Kesinlikle hayır. Amaç bu
değil. Amaç bir farkındalık yaratmak.
Sosyal medyayı kullanırken daha
bilinçli, daha özenli olmak. Yani hangi
kelimeyi nerede kullandığımızın farkına
varmak. Kısacası dilimizin direksiyonunu
yeniden kendi ellerimize almak. Ve bütün
bu proje aslında bize çok güçlü, çok
temel bir şey hatırlatıyor.
Düşünün be bir dilin geleceğini kim
belirler? Akademisyenler mi? Büyük
yazarlar mı? Aslında hayır. Bu proje
bize şunu gösteriyor. Bir dilin
geleceğini onu her gün kullanan bizler
yani sıradan insanlar belirler. Sokakta,
işte, sosyal medyada. Güç dili pasifçe
tüketenlerde değil, onu bilinçli bir
şekilde koruyan ve kullanan aktif
kullanıcılardadır.
Ve tüm bunlar bizi sonunda cevaplamamız
gereken o büyük soruyla başa bırakıyor.
Şöyle bir kendimize soralım. Bizim
dilimizin yani her gün kullandığımız
kelimelerin direksiyonunda kim var?
Gerçekten biz mi oturuyoruz yoksa
farkında olmadan o direksiyonu sosyal
medya algoritmalarına mı bıraktık? İşte
bu sorunun cevabı hepimizde saklı.